[Music]
thank you
now this is some really original sci-fi
I bought myself a ticket for Vesper a
month or two ago and I ended up in one
of the first showings with a question
and answer from the filmmakers hosted by
Ryan Johnson of The Last Jedi and knives
out thing and many other things wow wow
howdy howdy howdy welcome back to M
cubed I am your host Harris and welcome
back to Sidetrack that's right I'm a
partial host of the Sidetrack Channel
now so we're gonna be doing movie
reviews over on both M cubed and
Sidetrack now and today we are back with
another particular skip it this time
over the very original sci-fi film
Vesper so in a ticket or skip it we go
over four questions and in answering
those four questions we figure out
whether you should get a ticket you
should skip it or you should get a
ticket but have a little bit of
trepidation going into that movie so
without further Ado let's do further
[Music]
so our first question is was the film
itself fulfilling I think this film does
provoke your mind to think because it's
such a rich world that has been built
I'm a sucker for some World building but
this doesn't take away from any
character story at all this is such a
heavily character driven story that just
builds upon the world that is at the
characters Feats it's really really
meticulously and well done with the
crafting of this world the Technologies
the faunas maybe my favorite part of
this movie I'm raised from the swamp
really the marshes and no there was
nothing like this back where I'm from
but that very rudimentary nature kind of
taking back over it was familiar in an
odd way I really enjoyed it and I found
this film extremely fulfilling so that
brings me into question number two were
the characters arcs in this film
fulfilling let's start with the daughter
and the father Duo that lead the movie
so first up we have Rafaela Chapman
playing the title character of Vesper
and she does wonderful I don't think
I've ever seen her in anything before
but she looks like she could have came
right out of Game of Thrones or
something like that because she's a
young actress and for a young actress to
have this well acted and performed of a
role it's a testament to their ability
and their craft when they can do a
performance like this at an age so young
she's excellent in this and she brings a
really nice weight and gravitas to this
role into the world you get to delve
into her mind and many other things
through that and it really enriches
anything and everything brought to the
screen in those moments that brings us
to Richard breaks character Darius who
for the most part is a voice over role
of a drone flying around next to Vesper
I can't really give too much away but
her father is in a certain condition and
he's kind of bedridden the acting with
that is amazing yes this character's Arc
is the most fulfilling I think Arc of
the entire film the guy is excellent
with just being very stoic staunch not
saying a word literally just acting
through his eyes because he's paralyzed
he's a [ __ ] and then the voice acting
role of his is just as good if not
better at times is because you get
emotions from the floating Droid that's
hanging out you know and you get that
father-daughter kind of dynamic within
two different ways it's beautiful
it's beautifully done so then that
brings us to Eddie marzin's character
darius's brother Jonas kind of the
leader of the town he's kind of our
villain and you know there's some
complications in there if you really
look at it there he's not a very good
guy by any means but he's doing things
for survival I would say his Arc is very
fulfilling I like the way everything
pans out for him and the story really
takes hold whenever he enters the screen
and I mean it's Eddie Martin this guy
acts so well in anything and everything
he does finally that brings us to Rory
mcewen's Camellia and she kind of rounds
out that main main cast there are a
couple minor characters throughout here
and there but that is our kind of main
titular for character cast and she does
really excellent with this there's a
couple two Western turns in there
there's subtleties to it that are just
amazing and then that brings me into our
third question did I personally enjoy
this film and I've kind of answered this
one already yeah I really enjoy this
this is one of the most original sci-fi
things we've had over the past few years
and that actually hurts me saying that
because there are a lot of smaller
budget like very original sci-fi things
going on it doesn't expand its scope too
too much and it doesn't necessarily try
to take you out of a reality that you've
been set in like everything ever all at
once the comparison there is more so
just with originality Bruno samper and
Christina bosite the two directors for
this film and I believe Brian Clark the
writer their originality is not as crazy
per se but just as consistent and just
as well done it is extremely
meticulously crafted and you can feel
that while you're walking around the
world you feel it in the characters the
way they act the way they think the way
they talk I really enjoyed this film
that brings me into our fourth question
is this film worth you watching it's
such an original sci-fi tale that I
would be remiss to tell you not to go
watch it it is very Bleak but in a very
beautiful way you get to see the colors
of Life come through the bleakness you
feel new life as well as old life
decaying life there's all of it all
visually just right at your Forefront
but at the end of the day it really
hones in on the rebirth so that leaves
us with our decision should you get a
ticket should you skip it should you get
a ticket with just the trepidation going
into this one no drop the trepidation at
the door keep your ticket with you in
fact grab anybody and everybody you got
that you can grab alongside you and go
see this movie it deserves to be seen in
a movie theater I can't say enough it's
beautiful I loved it I really loved it
and I think you will too tell me what
you thought of Vesper down in the
comments below now if you'd like to
support our Channel you could do so by
clicking the like the Subscribe that
notification Bell down there and sharing
this anywhere and everywhere you can
thank you for watching this video and
thank you for Jamie over at Sidetrack
and we will see you in the next one
[Music]
thank you